the human brain is the most powerful
supercomputer in the world all right
let's see this electrical headquarters
of yours Marbury
it helps us navigate our environment by
carrying out about 1,000 trillion
logical operations per second
it's compact uses less power than a
light bulb and has potentially endless
storage the human brain is really one of
the most complex system that we can
imagine we have a fundamental lack in
our understanding of the way the
components in the brain interact but it
is this very interaction that generates
cognition and consciousness all these
mind-boggling intricacies have driven
our fascination with the brain and for
centuries we've been trying to map and
understand it most recently replicated
the brain is certainly a computer that
has been evolving for nearly 4 billion
years and the more we learn about the
brain the more we are able to
incorporate the smart ways that it does
computation into our artificial devices
scientists are beginning to agree that
to realize our technological dreams we
need to build computers that work like
our brains
one day these computers could in turn
help us unlock more secrets of cognition
the brain is packed with neuron cells
that constantly communicate with each
other through electrical pulses known as
spikes each neuron releases molecules
that act as messengers and control if
the electrical pulse is passed along the
chain this relay race is happening
simultaneously throughout billions of
neurons much like the zeros and ones of
the computer world this is the basic
language of the brain but understanding
all of this isn't enough
we've still only scratched the surface
when it comes to figuring out how the
brain works the more I'm working on the
brains and more I understand how complex
it is how how difficult it is many
relatively easy cognitive functions
cannot really be understood at the level
of cells the human brain is one of the
biggest secrets and mysteries that we
have despite many years of intensive
work Catrin Aman's is at the helm of the
human brain project a 10-year long
attempt at studying the brain with
researchers collaborating across 100
universities the project is expected to
cost around 1 billion euros
professor Amundsen her team are working
on one part of it a 3d digital brain
Atlas they're creating three different
high resolution maps one of neurons
one of their connections which uses
different colors to indicate the
orientation of neurons branches and one
map of the receptors for the messenger
molecules when we think about an atlas
of the world we can map all the
different countries but then we can also
see there are maps illustrating the
level above the sheep or the temperature
and it's a little bit like what we have
in the human brain there are different
aspects we want to understand where the
cells are located we want to understand
where so the areas are located how they
are connected were to say a molecular
profile what is a gene expression that
is important for function so there is
not one single aspect that can explain
everything in the human brain so that
means we need different types of maps
that reflect different aspects of brain
organization to create the maps the team
is scanning slices of postmortem brains
you get brains from body donors and
process them embed them in paraffin and
then cut them into 20 micrometer thick
sections 20 micrometer is approximately
like thickness of one hair so this is
very thin one brain has approximately
7,000 sections these sections can then
be analyzed under the microscope and we
can then reconstruct the areas in 3d
much like a fingerprint every brain is
unique so to account for these
differences the team scan 10 brains for
each of their maps this generates
petabytes of data that's analyzed with
the help of AI and used to run brain
simulations on supercomputers but even
the supercomputers struggle so to
further our understanding of the brain
we need better machines
we cannot make our chips much faster
without the melting unless we design
completely new architectures we cannot
make our components much smaller because
then we reach component sizes where
quantum effects take over so the
computation becomes too imprecise to be
practical we need to find better
solutions in order to increase our
computational power Mihai Petrovitch
like many other sciences in the field
thinks that model and computer hardware
on our brains is the way to go it will
not only increase the speed and
efficiency of future machines but also
help build better AI there are certainly
things that computers do much better
than brains such as adding or
multiplying big numbers because this is
what they were designed for intricate
problems in mathematics are accurately
solved in a minut fraction of the time
required for human calculation there is
no evolutionary pressure for us to be
able to multiply big numbers otherwise
certainly our brains would be able to do
it however there is a strong
evolutionary pressure to recognize your
surroundings to be able to build an
internal model of your surroundings when
you hear a noise in the bushes to be
able to imagine that maybe there's a
predator there to be able to recognize
faces in order to live in a society
where people can actually communicate
and cooperate and this is what evolution
has made our brains excel at this
ability to build an internal model of
the world to have sort of the world
inside your heads to imagine what is
happening around you even if you don't
see it this is of critical importance
for a true artificial intelligence AI
like Google image recognition Alexa or
the autopilot in a self-driving car all
work thanks to neural networks software
which already tries to imitate the way
our brain recognizes
bassam's one thing that today's
artificial intelligence needs in order
to be able to perform whatever task it
was designed for is a lot of examples so
in order for Google for example to be
able to show you pictures of cats
whenever you type in cat it needs to
have seen millions of images of cats
that is certainly not how we humans
operate and learn when you show a child
for example a cat or whatever other new
thing it just needs to see it a couple
of times in order to quickly grasp the
main features that are specific for that
animal and then recognize it whenever it
sees another individual of the species
the scientists at Heidelberg University
are working on a different part of the
human brain project they're using the
brain maps developed by Professor Amnon
tsa's team to build computer hardware
they hope will help a iLearn like our
brains do this new hardware is called
neuromorphic which means formed like
neurons or like the brain actually none
of what you see here on the outside is
really neurotic you might be tempted to
think that this is more or less like the
machine that you have at home on or
under your desk this would be true for
the outside components but at the heart
of the system there lies a piece of
hardware that is fundamentally radically
different from the chips in your
computer and that is the neuromorphic
heart of the system the microchips on
these wafers look nothing like the
entangled web of neurons that we have in
our heads
but each component communicates like an
individual neuron by sending along
spikes of electricity to their many
partners this design immensely increases
the operating speed neuromorphic
hardware generates results 10 million
times faster than conventional hardware
we certainly believe that this will
become a big thing we will see many
applications of these systems for
everyday tasks one of them would be face
recognition pattern recognition in
general speech recognition the ability
to read texts the ultimate goal of
course is to create true artificial
intelligence but it's really hard to say
by when we will be able to actually copy
the brain in an artificial substrate
what we can certainly do and what we are
doing right now is understand particular
aspects of computation in the brain the
four million artificial neurons packed
into this neuromorphic computer are just
a tiny fraction of the 86 billion
neurons in the human brain still it's a
big step forward for the machines
[Music]
even though our knowledge of the brain
has increased over the last few decades
it's still fragmented if the human brain
project is successful it could bring
this knowledge together and encourage
research and collaboration across
different scientific fields and so this
effort could be just the beginning of
the journey better understanding the
human brain is really one of the
challenges of the 21st century we have
an increasing amount of people suffering
from new degenerative diseases suffer
information depression adds up
psychiatric diseases we need to have new
tools to diagnose and have better
therapies for these brain diseases and
since we are living in an aging
population these diseases of course
player and major role in the future
[Music]